[Music]
welcome everyone
just some more very chat have you guys
ever play this how's it going broski's I
have arrived
hello what's up hello that's up right
hey good song
I am new to the oculus I got the oculus
for Christmas it took you a month to set
it up hey look at that boy I'm sorry
there's like no content here I'm sorry
oh hell yeah
have you guys never heard this song you
heard this on oh wow I am in Japan oh
wow and I'm PewDiePie okay stop it Tara
commands peopIe this
[Laughter]
I always see sushi dance Oh cringing
come out with your hands above your head
what happy what happened they took me
what if does that mean Master Chief
I can't master TV oh I killed Bao said
I'm so sorry I'm sorry this is the GTA
she was a thought she had to die I'm
sorry what not
that's what eat girls get my name is
Betty Pitt I'm the Sun destroyer
hey it's master cheap dude I saved your
life how about a thanks master chef
I can't high five I've got guns in my
hands right it's blue our team Hey
a fraud let's go guys it's a PewDiePie
thank you very much oh the thought he's
coming careful boys oh my god good job
Frogg great we have a handicap
spider-man on their side great I meant -
spider-man I meant and 100% all right
we'll use spider-man has shield
let's follow him what do you do in
spider-man you should spider web oh my
god spider-man saved my life
thanks spider-man how about a Spidey hug
how does that work
he saved my life he's a hero nice
got'em got'em nice all right I should
probably go live how's it going bros oh
my god oh my god dude you're beautiful
oh my god are you Petey play oh god I
see clothes please stops hey hey is that
a tire yeah are you tired no I'm not
certified why would this impact Oh God
oh my god Scoob we got waves oh my god
solid us hey it's me that's definitely
how you pronounce my name thank you okay
well I'm not planning to Jesus what the
[ __ ] it's Christ my mouth look like it's
random person and then I started
watching you came out of a person I mean
that's day what sighs wait let me look
at you let's see it chilling chicken
beautybay oh yeah
[Music]
that was beautiful
[Applause]
clap it up for care karmak beautiful ten
years of practice I was all a tick hey
guys what's up its why luigi here hey
Wang oh hey you promised you wouldn't
tell me you promised you would I tell
Sarah listen you had a deal okay what's
between them you're a penguin shut up I
don't need judge me Hey look I'm one of
you guys willing cease what is the I
forgot whoa how do I do this I have
powers it's a new body kids now I'm I
miss you
please I miss you there's a new sheriff
in Madagascar and he ain't playing
around and I don't care who's
handicapped come back here spider-man
spider-man I don't care if you're in the
wheelchair you're gonna die spider-man
that's what you get aah aah you suck ass
well for once son there he is
hey careful [ __ ] congratulations
bandage well done
just want to say big congrats hey
spider-man what
we're the same what do you want do you
know the weight fighter mode M hey can
we tiny sneeze in a can I do stuff pitch
oh I like that
vitamin I know what you're going through
all right spider-man is just angry
come on spider-man you're going with me
all right spider out
god I'm spider-man that's why you don't
quit fighting you want some of this
spider you won some money
you want some of this hey where are you
going come back here what'd I say
spiders got to to one's loaded plant
come I will over your head and no one
gets to hurt hands above your head and
we won't shoot that's right now dance
dance games for spider-man dance was
fighting man
what will your guilt for you I mean it
had to be done I'm sorry
anything damn it's a spider rule you
should know they provide a man you
should know they hey let's touch their
tips again let's uh shower leg I like
that
come on let's flap them together okay
look at my legs
[Music]
yeah thanks Bob Oregon whichever will it
be sister Dan sees the reason he deserve
the realty yes oh man I subscribe him at
least you take the account oh yeah are
you subscriber pity pie are you sure
good sit down they can see right here
take a seat right here if you put that
knife away then yes okay there you go
okay ah hey baby what's up ah yeah yeah
pieces how dare you you will all pay for
what you did take my knife give me the
gun give me the gun give me the gun stop
it just give me the gun give me the gun
oh my gosh you want pyramids we got them
oh you're into castles huh we got you
covered baby you want some bets easy we
got it all this game is still relevant
god damn it
[Music]